[MUSIC PLAYING]
SELIM EDDE: So good
afternoon, good morning,
and good evening to our Googlers
and whoever is watching us
across the world.
I have the immense pleasure
this afternoon here
in Dubai in the
United Arab Emirates
to welcome her Excellency, Noura
Al Kaabi, Minister of Culture
and Knowledge Development
for the United Arab Emirates.
NOURA AL KAABI: Thank you.
Thank you, Selim.
[APPLAUSE]
SELIM EDDE: I would like
to introduce properly
Her Excellency.
So if you don't mind,
I have to read this,
because it's so special.
NOURA AL KAABI: Thank you.
SELIM EDDE: So Her
Excellency Noura bint
Mohammed Al Kaabi was appointed
as UAE Minister of Culture
and Knowledge Development
in October 2017--
so a little bit over a year.
NOURA AL KAABI: Yep.
SELIM EDDE: And as Minister
of Culture and Knowledge
Development, Her Excellency is
responsible for the promotion
of the UAE cultural
fields on both
a national and
international level.
So in addition to her
ministerial responsibility,
Her Excellency is President
of Zayed University.
She also holds the
position as Chairwoman
of the Media Zone Authority
in Abu Dhabi and twofour54,
the home of media and
entertainment in Abu Dhabi.
She is Chair of Abu
Dhabi Media Company
and Chair of ADNEC, Abu Dhabi
National Exhibition Company.
She is also on the board of
the UAE National Media Council.
You see why I had
to read all this.
[LAUGHTER]
And she was previously,
as well, Minister
of State for the Federal
National Council of the UAE,
which is the equivalent
of the parliament.
NOURA AL KAABI:
Parliament-- yes.
SELIM EDDE: And
her claim to fame
is not only due to her
ministerial positions.
I have to also
share this with you.
Because Her Excellency
is the first UAE
national to be ranked
in "Foreign Policy"
magazine's top 100
global thinkers list.
And--
NOURA AL KAABI: It's outdated.
[LAUGHTER]
SELIM EDDE: It's still relevant.
And in 2014, she
was named as one
of the Forbes' Middle East's
30 most influential women
in government.
Her role in growing the
UAE's media industry
was recognized by America
Abroad Media in 2015.
And she was named as
one of the 20 most
powerful women in
global television
by the Hollywood
Reporter in 2016.
And she has been a World
Economic Forum [INAUDIBLE]
young global leader since 2014.
So with this, I can't
tell you how excited
we are, as Googlers, to have
you here in our modest office
here in Dubai.
And we are really
looking forward
to this encounter with you.
NOURA AL KAABI: Thank you.
Thank you, Selim.
It's such a pleasure
and honor to be here.
And also, thank you
for the picture.
I was looking for a
10-years challenge picture.
[LAUGHTER]
So that would work.
That would work.
It was in my old
office in twofour54.
And yeah-- Selim, again,
you've been a great supporter
of what we're doing.
I remember last Feb, during
the Future of Culture retreat
that we had under the beautiful
dome of Louvre Abu Dhabi.
SELIM EDDE: Memorable.
NOURA AL KAABI: We talked
about the future of culture.
SELIM EDDE: Yes.
NOURA AL KAABI: And
this is what we're
doing, where we are right
now-- talking to you,
talking to individuals here
in such a beautiful office.
You are the future.
And I believe we are
in the right place.
SELIM EDDE: Thank you.
So as you know, this
is Talks for Google.
And it's broadcasted
all over the world.
So the audience really is
curious to know a little bit
more about Noura Al Kaabi,
Her Excellency, your life,
your journey.
NOURA AL KAABI: OK.
SELIM EDDE: So if you don't mind
telling us a little bit more
how it all started.
NOURA AL KAABI:
OK-- so of course,
I'm born here in the UAE.
I've lived my whole life here.
And I studied in the
UAE, except for a year
in the United States.
It was during my junior high.
It was a year where--
it defined the way I see
a totally new culture.
We in the UAE--
being here, the closest
culture to us is either--
of course, the Arab
culture is the closest one.
But you have the Indian culture.
You have the European culture.
The American was kind of
a further down the road.
And back then, it
was the mid '90s,
so there wasn't
mobile phones yet.
And we weren't that
interconnected, such as today.
And that was the
period of time where
I got to know Oprah, the
OJ Simpson Bronco chase--
what else?
Many--
SELIM EDDE: On live TV.
NOURA AL KAABI: On live TV.
NOURA AL KAABI: And
I was like, this
is what happens when someone
just flees from a place
to another.
Anyway-- so it was such an
exciting time to be there,
to meet different people, and
to know a different culture.
And I think that also was
a kind of a tipping point,
in terms of the way we interact
with different nationalities.
We are in the UAE.
We do interact with
different nationalities.
But sometimes, it's kind
of a bubble when you're
in the States, even till today.
With the news you
see, the fashion,
whatever you're
consuming-- it is very much
tailored towards that market.
Coming back to
the UAE, I decided
to study computer science.
And after a year, I said,
this is not the major I want,
because I was--
[LAUGHTER]
SELIM EDDE: We're
learning something now.
NOURA AL KAABI: My
mother hated my decision,
because she wanted
me to finish--
she was heading a school
for a good 30 years.
And I was a student--
SELIM EDDE: She
was the headmaster.
NOURA AL KAABI: Yeah, she was
the headmaster of the school.
She has the teacher.
I was in her school
for six years.
And before that, I studied
three years in a private school.
And all of a sudden, I
see myself in her school.
And the reason why is because
I was writing Arabic from
left to right instead
of right to left.
[LAUGHTER]
So my mother didn't
notice my genius part.
She noticed that there is a
threat to the Arabic language.
So anyway-- I went
to the public school.
I'm very thankful,
because it really
helped my Arabic language.
SELIM EDDE: Interesting.
NOURA AL KAABI: So after
changing the major,
I studied management information
system at the UAE University
in Al Ain.
After that, my father was like--
he is a military person.
And for him, he doesn't
accept someone just
doing nothing at home.
And he was like, Noura,
you need to start working.
My first job was in
a military hospital,
just in an IT
department-- helpdesk--
fixing printers and
whatever it is--
on and off switching,
resetting PCs and [INAUDIBLE]..
[LAUGHTER]
The exciting part was learning
about the hospital management
information system.
So in the beginning
of 2002, it was just
something that was new.
And replacing papers
with automation
is fairly new back then.
After that, I've pursued
another career, which
is in the clean energy sector.
So I worked in Dolphin Energy
for a good 3 and 1/2 years.
SELIM EDDE: Dolphin-- the
major energy company in--
NOURA AL KAABI: Abu Dhabi--
SELIM EDDE: --Abu Dhabi.
NOURA AL KAABI: --yes.
And it was more to do with
training and development.
Because again, with my
career, it's funny enough.
Going to Dolphin Energy,
I wanted to be in IT.
Yet, at my first
day I was supposed
to go to the IT department.
And the HR lady
said, you know what?
We have a vacancy
for just three weeks
in training and development.
And I just want you to help
me manage that department.
So instead of three
weeks, it was three years.
Not planned-- yet, I
was thankful for it.
Because also, I realized
that dealing with people,
interacting with people,
understanding their career
progression-- whether they're
on the fields or in office--
was something that
is interesting.
Fast forward-- I
had a phone call
from my previous boss, His
Excellency Khaldoon Al Mubarak.
We were just talking
about-- what is next?
And what's next was a new
media city at Abu Dhabi.
So what does fascinate me--
and this is where I got into--
after getting out of
the elevators here
in your beautiful offices,
the map with [INAUDIBLE]----
characters that we grew
up watching, enjoying,
being inspired of.
And I asked myself a question.
I said, did we stop
creating content?
Because I end up
still watching content
that is not necessarily Arabic.
So channel 33 was a channel
that I enjoyed back then.
SELIM EDDE: That was the
English channel, right?
NOURA AL KAABI: That was
the English Channel here--
SELIM EDDE: In the UAE.
NOURA AL KAABI: --in the UAE.
And my favorite movies
were movies that
are not Arabic necessarily.
But I enjoyed some Arabic drama.
SELIM EDDE: Can I ask
your favorite movie?
NOURA AL KAABI:
Well, back then it
was "The Goonies," of
course, "ET," "Star Wars,"
and some animation.
I loved the dubbed animation.
Yet, it's dubbed.
Where is your content?
So this is what inspired me.
I said, OK.
Let's work on Media City-- its
twofour54, focusing on content,
in 2008.
SELIM EDDE: So we
were all intrigued
when we looked at your resume--
MIS or computer science
and minister of culture.
So you've sort of told us how
it actually came together.
NOURA AL KAABI: Yeah,
it's nice that those are
different phases in my career.
And media was a good
segue to be in culture.
Yes-- there was an
intervention being the Minister
of Federal National
Council Affairs, which
was a year and a half.
And the reason why
is because also I
was appointed parliament
member for four years.
And during that
time, I got appointed
to just change the seat
from being a member
to represent the government
for a year and a half.
So when the post happened with
being a minister of culture,
I said, OK, I think
I'm in my element
right now, when it comes
to doing what I'm doing.
SELIM EDDE: Wonderful--
so accelerating career
that really went
very, very quickly
from working in a hospital, if
I understand, to HR, et cetera.
I have a question.
Where is the inflection
point where you really
felt that things were
accelerating more
than [INAUDIBLE]?
NOURA AL KAABI: Yeah--
2008 upwards.
So--
SELIM EDDE: What happened?
NOURA AL KAABI: 10 years ago.
SELIM EDDE: What
was the moment you--
NOURA AL KAABI:
It was twofour54.
So it was working in twofour54.
And I remember, I was
just managing the center
that we make sure
that any company that
comes from outside the UAE to
Abu Dhabi, they feel like home.
This is a very easy setup.
And I've learned a lot
from even being here--
Dubai Internet City,
Media City, because it
started before Abu Dhabi.
Yeah-- so that was
the point where--
it was a tough five
years from 2008--
fast forward five years.
Because-- just trying
my best to build myself.
I had great mentors,
a great CEO,
who helped me to take
it to the next level.
SELIM EDDE: Great.
I researched a little bit.
I did a little bit of homework.
I read that you received
that phone call when
you were in Formula One racing.
NOURA AL KAABI: Yeah.
SELIM EDDE: And you
were attending, right?--
the Formula One?
NOURA AL KAABI: Yes.
SELIM EDDE: And they
announced to you
that you'd been nominated to
the Federal National Council.
NOURA AL KAABI: Yes.
SELIM EDDE: And
at that point, it
was some kind of a life change.
NOURA AL KAABI: Yeah--
that was the federal door.
And I remember getting
that phone call.
I was like, OK.
It's either I sit and enjoy and
watch the race and see Hamilton
winning and get everyone-- my
mom was there and my sisters--
or tell them now.
So I said, you know what?
Let's just watch the race.
We're done.
We had a quick dinner.
I got into the car.
I said, oh, by the way,
I got a call and XY.
SELIM EDDE: Your
father and mother
must have been very
proud at that time.
NOURA AL KAABI: They
played a strong role,
in terms of making sure that we
choose what we want to study,
what we want to major in.
For them, the only no-no
was getting low grades.
That was the only
thing, which is normal.
But other than that, they give
us the full freedom of support.
SELIM EDDE: Hint-hint
to four parents
in the room or listening.
NOURA AL KAABI: Now,
it's totally different.
Now, the kids can lecture you.
So--
[LAUGHTER]
So I'm not sure this is--
I think, the list of accepting
things is more than--
SELIM EDDE: Yes, I know
something about that.
So family is very important
in the Arab culture.
NOURA AL KAABI: Yeah.
SELIM EDDE: And maybe
this is a segue way
to ask you the question
about the United Arab Emirate
culture.
We all know, we have
such a rich heritage
as Arabs in the
United Arab Emirates.
I wanted, maybe, you to
share with the audience--
what is unique about the
United Arab Emirates?
NOURA AL KAABI: Well,
I know I'm Emirati
and I'm a government official.
Yet, I feel, by even
traveling outside of the UAE--
whether it's in the region,
outside the region--
I do understand the difference.
And when I say, a
difference, it's
not a difference that
happens just by day.
It's the consistent practice,
since the Founding Father
Sheikh Zayed, of the
country's inception,
of how he welcomed
different nationalities,
how we got different expertise.
I grew up in a school where
more than 50% of my classmates
were from Arabic countries.
And my accent or
dialect wasn't Emirati.
So when I was done from
my elementary school
to high school, my high school
had more percentage of Emiratis
than Arabs, because
of the neighborhood.
And they're like, are
you sure you're Emirati?
And I was like, yes, I am.
But it's just, also, I grew up
with different nationalities.
They were my best friends.
And then, looking at even
the way the companies
are here in the UAE.
I don't mind if my
boss was not Emirati.
I don't mind working
with a non-Emirati.
We would rather learn and
thrive and do our best.
And I feel, that
was a message that
was instilled by the late
founding father and founding
fathers of the UAE.
And it's a continuation
of what we're
doing in the way we do
business, in the way we
are in the restaurants, and
the way we are in schools.
It happens to be part
of our Emirati identity,
that we welcome
different nationalities
and we live with
different nationalities.
It's the Year of
Tolerance in the UAE.
And I feel, how we can take
it, also, to the next level--
especially that we are
living in a world that
is unfortunate in some places.
And we need to revisit
our values of how
we can do our best and
forget what differentiates us
and unite each other, instead of
the horrible things that we're
seeing.
SELIM EDDE: Indeed--
so thank you
for sharing this personal
view of the UAE culture.
We all travel.
And for the people who live
in Dubai or United Emirates,
when we travel
abroad, everyone talks
about the tallest building
in the world, which
is a feat by itself definitely.
Or they talk about
the Seven Star hotel.
And they talk about the
large malls and all that.
It's not only about this.
It's much more than that.
NOURA AL KAABI: Yeah.
SELIM EDDE: Although, I would
say that, for me, having
my kids growing up in a
city where the tallest
building in the
world was built--
this changes their
mindset and makes
them believe that
anything is possible.
So there is this also.
And it's highly appreciated
in the UAE culture, if I may.
NOURA AL KAABI: Yeah--
SELIM EDDE: If I may as a--
NOURA AL KAABI: --this
is what keeps us busy.
SELIM EDDE: So you have this--
[LAUGHTER]
NOURA AL KAABI: And everything--
when do you want it ready?
Oh, by yesterday.
Oh-- just wanted to know,
when is my deadline?
And it's always-- if it's
today, it's yesterday.
So I think that, by
itself, is also--
it's kind of the culture, Selim.
Again, I hate comparing.
But this is where, sometimes,
in certain cultures--
OK, we've started looking
at work differently.
It's your whole day.
Yet, you need to also
give yourself a break.
You need to have time
for your family, workout,
yoga-- whatever it is.
But it's just how
it's essential to also
be available and committed.
And I think that's what also
differentiates us from others,
because there is always--
we feel it's a competition.
We feel it's a good
competition to do better.
SELIM EDDE: Yes-- so our
values behind the essence
of the culture-- there are some
strong values, like commitment
and tolerance and welcoming.
We all know that 80%
are expats in the UAE.
This is for our international
audience as well.
And we live peacefully.
And--
NOURA AL KAABI: I think, we--
SELIM EDDE: --work side by side.
NOURA AL KAABI:
Yeah, we talk a lot
about the percentage of the
Emiratis and the non-Emiratis.
Yet, I feel proud that
there's this achievement
of-- and a united Arab
Emirates is not because of just
the Emirati.
It's because of the Emirati
accepting the other,
because of the Emirati
working with the others,
because the Emirati helping
other companies to set up
and take it to the next level.
So I feel, it's luckily
not looking into borders.
And that is something
that defines the values
that we work on.
SELIM EDDE: Brilliant--
let me push a little bit
further this point.
Because the cynical people would
say that I have my culture.
You have your culture.
Therefore, we're different.
And then 15 minutes
later, they'll be arguing.
And then some other
bad things happen.
OK-- so it could be misused
as a way to differentiate
and divide people.
NOURA AL KAABI: Mm-hm.
SELIM EDDE: Your message
is a very strong one
about unifying-- the culture
unifying people coming
from various places.
Can you just--
NOURA AL KAABI: Sure--
we've been living in a
culture that is multicultural.
And we tend to consume content
that is not necessarily Arabic.
We also have people
working with us.
And we're working with people
who see our culture in a way.
And we see their
culture in a way.
And at the end of
the day, it's just
the way of how the
more different cultures
you have is the more enriched
you are in your own city.
What defines a vibrant city
is the different cultures,
the different--
I don't know-- the way they
dress, the food, the art,
the music.
And we always curious.
We always want to enjoy
music, not necessarily it's
only Arabic music.
Or we want to enjoy food--
not necessarily it's
Arabic food or Emirati food.
So you see culture,
getting people
connected in a way
that is different
than any other sector.
So if it's a political,
if it's economy,
if it's whatever it is, it's the
same people meeting, talking,
based on the same topics.
When it comes to culture, this
is where it's very enriched.
And this is where us, even
at the Ministry of Culture
and Knowledge
Development-- we've
been doing our best to work
with different cultures.
So when the Chinese
president visited the UAE,
we wanted to make sure we
activate the UAE in a way
that our guests, who are
the Chinese delegations
and Chinese people working in
the UAE, know more about us.
And again, at the
same time-- how
the community, Emiratis
or non-Emiratis,
know about the Chinese
culture-- from food,
from music, from
fashion, from art.
And this is where we
activated the whole city.
And there was also a digital
Chinese radio channel
that is based here
in Dubai, under ARN,
that is purely Mandarin.
So by that, you're
enriching and spreading
the knowledge of a
different culture.
Again, in March, we're going
to have the Zayed-Gandhi
Exhibition in Abu Dhabi.
Why do we have the Zayed-Gandhi?
Both personalities--
we traced their values,
in terms of leadership,
tolerance, harmony,
coexistence, humbleness--
and how can we
also exhibit that in the UAE
and exhibit it in New Delhi
and India at the same time?
So I feel, with culture--
yes-- when it's
different, it's rich.
SELIM EDDE: Fantastic.
NOURA AL KAABI: It doesn't
mean, when it's different,
it's opposite.
SELIM EDDE: I have to mention
the Louvre in all this--
the Louvre in Abu
Dhabi, which is--
NOURA AL KAABI: Yeah--
sure.
SELIM EDDE: If you
have not visited it,
you have to visit it.
And it talks exactly
about that, where you have
meeting of cultures, right?
NOURA AL KAABI: Yes.
What's so beautiful about
the Louvre Abu Dhabi
is it's created in
a way that it gets
different cultures in same
halls, yet different time
frames.
So it's different time zones,
with more than one culture
at the same time.
SELIM EDDE: Exactly.
NOURA AL KAABI: And there's also
the Beliefs and the Holy room,
where you get to see the Torah.
You can see the Bible.
You can see the other
beliefs in one room.
So there is the religion.
There's the art.
There are the different
civilizations.
And this, by itself, defines
the future of a museum.
You get into the museum.
You wait to go to which hall.
But what makes this
a different museum--
for me, I got to know--
it's a faster learning
process, for me personally,
to see that in one room,
instead of getting from a hall
to another.
And I think, the
Louvre Abu Dhabi
also defines what having
different cultures in one
place-- how does it look like?
SELIM EDDE: Yes--
and in practice.
NOURA AL KAABI: In
practice-- exactly.
SELIM EDDE: And this is
what's beautiful about it.
NOURA AL KAABI: Exactly.
SELIM EDDE: So you are
the Minister of Culture
and Knowledge Development.
Everyone is really fascinated by
the knowledge development part,
right?
NOURA AL KAABI: So I'm
developing your knowledge--
yes.
[LAUGHTER]
SELIM EDDE: We're
learning every day.
NOURA AL KAABI: We are
SELIM EDDE: And you have this
beautiful infrastructure,
where great things are
happening in the country.
No pressure-- but what's your
vision, as Minister of Culture?
NOURA AL KAABI: Well, we're
very much excited by 2019.
It's a year where we're
going to talk more
about our strategy and creative
and cultural index, which
we announced during
the event that we had
with His Highness [INAUDIBLE]
bin Rashid in the Louvre
in February.
So that index, by
itself, also will
help us measure the creative
and cultural sector.
It's an impactful sector.
Yet, we need to quantify
it and support it.
We are a ministry that
not just regulates.
But also, we want to stimulate
the cultural scene in the UAE.
Creative skills are
skills of the future.
We need to elevate that
in a way that there
are the right policies
that we should put.
There is also the right way to
attract talents, develop them,
train them.
And this is where we have
our talents policy that we
will also be working on.
We have many questions of--
what do we have in the UAE?
Whether it's the
tangible heritage
or the intangible
heritage, cultural events
happening-- we're going to
get all of that in something
called the UAE
Cultural Map, which
we hope to be a smart
map, such as the Google.
And this is where, also,
we got our residents--
SELIM EDDE: We
accept the challenge.
NOURA AL KAABI: --and
tourists to know
what's happening in a
way that is interactive
and in a way that helps--
also, for any individuals
who comes to the UAE
for the first time,
they will just talk about
the most popular cities
or Emirates.
Is it Dubai?
Is Abu Dhabi?
Is it Sharjah?
Yet, we're also
working on activating
the other cultural centers
in the northern Emirates.
Each emirate has it's niche,
in a way, from an archeology,
from performance, from
filming, from theater.
So how can we activate that
with the right partners?
The Ministry can't do
this work by itself.
We have to work
with our partners,
where they're local
entities or private sector
again at the same time.
SELIM EDDE: Right-- great.
So the UAE has always
delivered on vision,
in terms of when it comes
to brick and mortar--
if I may challenge a little bit.
So we've built the
most beautiful hotels,
the tallest building in
the world, et cetera.
How are you going to make
sure-- because a lot of leaders
in our Middle East and North
Africa region have visions.
But what happens is that they
fail on the implementation
part, especially when it comes
to the soft part, like culture.
NOURA AL KAABI: Yeah.
SELIM EDDE: So
what is it that you
will be doing to make sure
that you will actually deliver
on this beautiful vision?
NOURA AL KAABI: Well, number
one is-- the vision is set.
The strategy is set.
The roadmap's clear.
From that roadmap, we
have, of course, our plans
and what are we
going to accomplish
during the upcoming
three to five years.
This is just set.
And this is something that is
approved by our leadership.
And as a ministry, it
is also, how can we
track such achievements?
So we do have projects
that we're working on.
And those projects-- how
to ensure this vision
is being achievable
is-- even for us,
we worked on a vision
that is achievable.
We worked on a way,
also, to partner
with different entities--
local entities, individuals,
private sector--
to help us achieve what we want
to be achieving in the culture
sector.
So you said, it's a soft?
It's a serious business.
It's not just soft.
Why is it a serious business?
Because you're
looking at developing
the best policies for culture.
SELIM EDDE: Yes, I--
NOURA AL KAABI: You
work also on the index.
That is something
that is not soft.
That's something that's
achievable, measurable.
You're working on talents.
You need a database
to get those talents.
Where are they?
Are we attracting them?
Are we discovering them?
Are they in schools?
Are they graduates?
And some talents
are outside the UAE?
How can I attract
wonderful people who
are talented outside the UAE?
The same way we attract
scientists and business
specialists-- how can we
attract talents and artist
to have UAE as a base?
So we make sure, Selim, that
we quantify what we're doing.
There are results, which is
a nice art piece, musical--
whatever it is-- that
can't be measured in a way
that's quantifiable.
Yet, we're sure that there
is this strategic impact when
it comes to a youth
culture happening
in the middle of nowhere and
people wanting to come and see
it.
And we do benchmark
the best practices.
We make sure, as well,
that quarterly we're
looking at our
progression and, again,
looking at the UAE government.
And I don't think we have
room for just skipping a point
or skipping something, because
I'll be asked, why didn't we
achieve XY?
SELIM EDDE: Yes-- may
I ask you a totally
disinterested question?
NOURA AL KAABI: OK.
SELIM EDDE: How policy
and technology can
help you achieve your vision?
And I must say--
a vivid moment was last year
in the World Government Summit
that takes place in
Dubai in February,
where you were on your panel--
really, a member of
a panel with Amit
Sood, who is the head of
our Google Arts and Culture.
And you had a very
interesting debate.
NOURA AL KAABI: Yeah.
SELIM EDDE: OK-- and he talked
about giving people access
to art and culture,
spreading it, and--
not only that-- having content.
Because if you have
access without content--
NOURA AL KAABI: Ah.
SELIM EDDE: And you
need to have context
curating those pieces of art.
And the last element,
which is typically Amit--
and I'm sure you
embrace that as well--
is fun.
He said, you need
to have fun as well.
NOURA AL KAABI: Absolutely.
SELIM EDDE: And
bringing back the coder
that your mother
wanted you to be
or the MIS manager that
you actually became--
how technology can help bring
your vision into reality?
NOURA AL KAABI: Sure--
so whatever we do now, we
can't do without technology.
We can't.
SELIM EDDE: Even in culture?
NOURA AL KAABI: Even in
culture, whatever policies
we are working on, it has
to have the future in it.
What's the future?
Technology platforms--
artificial intelligence
is something that, now,
everyone's talking about it.
But it has been there for the
past-- more than 10 years.
I can say that I
use a Pixel phone.
And it is a true smartphone
than other phones,
because it's-- it's just
crazy how a device knows you--
the news and everything and how
everything is interconnected.
So it's a way-- how can we work
hand-in-hand with technology?--
yet again, at the
same time, make
sure that it's an
enabling policy?
I personally don't understand
anything that [INAUDIBLE]
the progress of you
building a policy.
Again, at the same time, with
our discussions with Amit--
how it's crucial to have
accessibility to content or art
content that is and in places
that you don't travel to.
It's an essential
tool for education,
for building your education.
And I think that, by itself,
also will help our projects
and will help our story as well.
SELIM EDDE: Absolutely.
NOURA AL KAABI:
There is also the
build of the 3D model of
Palmyra that the Future
Foundation worked on.
For us, Selim, we are working on
a project of rebuilding Al Nuri
Mosque in Mosul in Iraq.
And the story of Al Nuri Mosque
is-- unfortunately, it's--
SELIM EDDE: So it's beyond
the United Arab Emirates.
You have a regional
calling as well.
NOURA AL KAABI: Yes--
a region calling.
And for us, the endangered
sites are an important--
let's say-- element in whatever
we're doing in our ministry,
to help also to--
SELIM EDDE: Can you just
expand briefly on this?
Because in [INAUDIBLE]
in the MENA region,
in the Middle East and
North Africa region,
are quite a thing.
NOURA AL KAABI:
Yeah, unfortunately,
most of the places happen
to be a war zone because
of certain breaches.
And the most important
thing is, where do we
see the opportunity, when
it comes to culture?--
and culture that,
also, we're related to.
So when I talk about
rebuilding Al Nuri Mosque--
and this is a directive we
got from the government,
to go to Baghdad, announce
rebuilding the mosque.
That will take five years-- and
in partnership with the UNESCO.
And who will help us in
building the Al Nuri Mosque
are also the youth in Mosul
and the youth in Baghdad.
And you need to
understand, those
universities-- they used to be
the renaissance of universities
in the region.
Not anymore-- now, they don't
even have decent scanners so.
How can we utilize the
know-how in rebuilding
and reconstructing the
mosque and-- again,
at the same time getting youth
who are studying archeology
to understand
using technology?--
understand using technology
to get lessons from other
specialized institutions
outside Iraq?
Or again, at the
same time, also,
if we can support the
exhibition of Al Nuri Mosque
in a way that documents
it and makes people
understand the context of
why do we want to do that--
there will be more
projects happening,
because unfortunately there
are many endangered sites.
The exciting part is that
there will be jobs and future.
And we can't not have technology
to be part of such rebuilds.
SELIM EDDE: Wonderful-- you
also mentioned the word "youth."
NOURA AL KAABI: Yes.
SELIM EDDE: And I
think it is critical.
And I know, it's dear
to you, because you
have an army of young people--
you will enlist
them and mobilize
them to serve the culture
in the vision that you have,
which is beautiful, with
the help of technology
and policies.
Policies are important, right?
NOURA AL KAABI: Absolutely.
And Selim, in the region, there
are more than 50% to 60% youth
in our region-- in the UAE, 49%.
SELIM EDDE: Under 25 years old.
NOURA AL KAABI:
Under 25 years old.
SELIM EDDE: Yeah-- great.
Well, one last
question, which is--
you have accustomed
us to big things.
So I have to ask the
question, because it's--
what is the next big thing?
NOURA AL KAABI: Well,
the next big thing is--
we're truly working
towards making sure
that whatever we do in
the Ministry of Culture
is something that has an
impact, not just in the UAE,
but outside the UAE.
The next interesting
thing happening--
and I consider it
big-- we consider
it big-- is the Pope's visit
in February, here in the UAE.
It's the first visit of
the Pope in a GCC country.
We're going to celebrate
prior his visit.
Everyone is celebrating.
Everyone wants to
go to his mass.
And I think, he is a
personality that embodies values
that we embody here in the UAE.
So this is the next
big thing happening.
SELIM EDDE: Quite wonderful.
NOURA AL KAABI: So
it's beginning of Feb.
So-- yeah.
SELIM EDDE: Thank you so much.
Please give a--
[APPLAUSE]
NOURA AL KAABI: Thank you.
Thank you very much.
SELIM EDDE: --round of applause.
NOURA AL KAABI: Thank you.